foreign
that's right because of the countless
number of moments in anime we're back
with another top 10 one hit chaos in
anime you already know what I'm talking
about the overlooked moments that didn't
get into the previous list will be
getting their time to shine in this
sequel from the Marshall Carnage that is
Gengar Ashura to the obvious revisit
from beloved franchises such as one
punch man and bleach so without further
Ado let's drop into the top 10 one-hit
Kos in anime volume 2. let's start with
Gengar Ashura wakatsuki and murobachi's
fight
also known as the white tiger wakatsuki
Takeshi is the longest serving active
Affiliated Gengar fighter and has the
highest win record of all Affiliated
Fighters is one of the strongest
fighters in the Gengar matches oh due to
his unusually dense muscles this Powers
show many defeated murobachi Gozo in
what seemingly can't be called a fair
fight in the anime representing furumi
Pharmaceuticals Takeshi fought against
Gozo and from the outset he pulled no
punches opening the fight with a full
powered Hitman to defeat Gozo in a
single strike that's shown off in a
brutal punch to the gut that flung the
poor guy across the pit if you've ever
played the recent Mortal Kombat games
then you'd feel right at home with the
X-ray shot of muroboti's intestines
rupturing from the punch
speaking of putting fast ones doguro
isn't a big fan of them
doguro from YuYu Hakusho is one of if
not the strongest character in YuYu
Hakusho the former human turned demon is
the main antagonist of the Dark
Tournament Saga where he encounters
bhutajiri a lying cheetah with a name
that literally translates to pig's butt
it's such a scumbag that his actions
against team urameshi yusuke's team
angered sakyo and toguro the latter
killed the pig man with a single flick
to the forehead that caused the top of
his skull to burst in a spray of Blood
and Bone this just goes to show how
brutal toguro is but also how
dishonorable and disgusting the actions
of bhutajiriza that they offended the
main villain where normal people give
you the finger to just feel offended but
when doguro gives you the finger your
head explodes as you scream I swear 90s
anime have the most over-the-top and
unbelievable deaths for no reason
foreign
[Music]
blasting off our next entry we have the
air gasmic punch from yozakura quartet
with the members of the Izumi life
counseling office away for a trip it's
up to the local police to protect a pair
of siblings from a werewolf who comes
after their lives intending to sacrifice
them in an attempt to obtain immortality
after being bombarded by gunfire and
shot in the head Point Blank by a sniper
rifle the cocky werewolf seems to think
that he only needs to beat the alpha
which he thinks is takao that's when the
bald swordsman breaks the bad news to
him while nadishiko delivers the most
stunning punch after declaring that
she's the alpha the werewolf was punched
by a flaming fist holding a sword that
sent him barreling towards a squad of
police cars which then exploded yeah
it's as crazy as it sounds and it sounds
straight out of fire force even using
the millisecond of Silence before it
delivers the ear shaking base that's how
you sell an anime one punch knockout
equal rights and equal fights we have
the nun punch from Doma in A Certain
Magical Index
okay
[Music]
Doma got his unofficial title of nun
puncher when he faced off against Agnes
the fight ends with Thomas Victory after
he manages to break through Agnes's
defenses and reach her he then punches
her in the face with his imagine breaker
knocking her out and showing that his
fists don't discriminate even against
church members remember this all happens
while thorma's just a level zero the
lowest of lows in Academy City yet he's
able to go toe-to-toe against the
world's most powerful espers and
magicians and just punches them in the
face be it man or woman every scene
where Doma beats someone is accompanied
by Hype music and animation that makes
us cheer at every turn this scene in
particular wants us to celebrate our
great equalizer knocking out a nun Dorma
is a giga Chad amongst Giga Chads and
his nun punch is a reminder why
before we move on let me ask you a
question have you ever felt like the
Internet isn't a safe place heck let's
not even go down that route let's flat
out say that the internet is a dangerous
place fortunately you've got this video
sponsor expressvpn to save the day with
expressvpn all of my internet traffics
rerouted and encrypted through their
secure servers so I don't have to worry
about my internet provider seeing what
I'm doing or hackers on unencrypted
networks trying to steal my account log
into credit card details with expressvpn
you can change your location to a
country where the anime is available no
matter where you are in the world I use
it just this weekend to watch Hunter
Hunter which isn't available in the UK
all I had to do was open up expressvpn
and select the United States server and
boom now I can watch Hunter Hunter like
dozens of other anime on Netflix break
region locks overcome villains trying to
get your personal info and surf without
suffering any slowdowns in internet
speed so what's not to like no other VPN
I've used comes anywhere close to
expressvpn in terms of Effectiveness
ease of access and value for money you
can get three months of expressvp VPN
for free by following the link below or
typing in
www.expressvpn.com Vinnie tube a world
of safe browsing and an internet free of
limitations are at your fingertips
teleporting behind you we have datsuya
versus Hanzo in Irregular at Magic High
School
hello
probably one of the most famous one-hit
Kos in recent memory this is darsuya's
One-Shot defeat of Vice President Hanzo
Hattori happens in the second episode of
the first season it's his earliest
achievement in school that left the
school council and his classmates
wondering about his true identity
tatsuya and hathori's battle lasted only
seconds leaving tatsuya the winner Hanzo
even predicts that he won't lose because
blooms don't lose to weeds and yet just
like a redditor with the power of God
and Anime on his side datsuya rushes
behind him and uses his natural special
a gun this fight was so memorable since
it's one of the first at the beginning
of the anime that really showed us the
gap between tatsuya and the rest of the
so-called Elite we get to be smug
alongside her sister Miyuki as we see
the other council members gaspinor at
the small showing of his power
Joshua Shiva tatya
rushing onto our next entry we have the
rematch between Deku and muscular in the
latest my hero Academia
foreign
the match between Deku and muscular in
my hero Academia sixth season was one of
the most epic and emotional fights in
the series Deku faced muscular again
after their first encounter in the
forest training camp where Deku barely
managed to defeat him with the help of
Kota this time vigilante Deku had to
protect a group of civilians from
musculars Rampage while also testing his
new abilities with one for all now this
fight was intense and brutal as muscular
Unleashed his full power and Deku
struggle to keep up Deku used his black
Whip and danger sense quirks to gain an
edge over muscular he also displayed his
compassion and heroism as he tried to
reason with muscular and offer him a
chance to redeem himself however
muscular was too far gone and refused to
listen he only cared about satisfying
his bloodlust and fighting strong
opponents he pushed Deku to his limit
forcing him to use 45 percent of one for
all in the end they could delivered a
powerful Detroit smash that knocked down
muscular and saved the civilians ending
the fight without getting major injuries
and not even using a hundred percent
that previously defeated the villain
showed just how much more power powerful
and mature this version of Deku is
[Music]
next up we have Nagisa vs takaoka in
assassination classroom
magisa a timid and choir student was
challenged by dagolka a sadistic and
violent former instructor to a
one-on-one Knife Fight takolka had a
grudge against Nagisa for humiliating
him in a previous encounter and wanted
to make him suffer Nagisa accepted the
challenge despite being a disadvantage
in terms of strength size and experience
the fight was tense and brutal and
takaoka used his Superior speed and
power to overwhelm Nagisa he taunted and
mocked him trying to break his spirit
and make him beg for mercy magisight
endured the pain and fear to keep his
calling utilize his observation skills
to find an opening he remembered the
lessons he learned from his classmates
and teachers and used them to his
Advantage he exploited dakaroka's
arrogance and anger and tricked him into
lowering his guard he then delivered a
decisive blow to takaoka's neck using a
special technique that he learned from
lovrone he knocked out Darko with one
hit shocking everyone who witnessed the
fight the fight was a turning point for
Nagisa as he proved himself to be a
formidable assassin and a brave leader
he also earned the respect and
admiration of his class mates and
teachers who cheered for him and praised
him he showed that he wasn't afraid of
darker or anyone who threatened him or
his friends he demonstrated his growth
and potential as a student of class 3E
oh God
now with the anime that will always be
included in every one hit list we have
saitama's punch against the Deep Sea
King
the first major monster fight by
saithama after he officially registered
in the hero Association saithama and the
deep sea King's fight was absolutely one
of the most epic battles in one punch
man when Deep Sea King invaded Jay City
he stopped everyone even genos and the
muffin role that is movement Rider but
what he didn't know was that he isn't
the only monster in town after saitama
saved movement Rider Deep Sea King
thought he was just fodder like the rest
but he couldn't be more wrong with just
one casual punch saithama ended the
fight making Deep Sea King join the
donut group along with rengoku the punch
was so strong that it even stopped the
rain everyone's mouth was wide open but
saithama was just disappointed by how
easy the fight was not us viewers though
because of course the anime is called
one punch man this is probably one of
the best animated moments in the first
season the slo-mo punch of the Deep Sea
King sets him up to be an intimidating
monster that Towers over saithama his
attack almost seemed like always done
but we're still just brushed aside by
the one punch that made the world stay
still for a moment saitama more like a
deuce ex machina that comes at the last
minute to save the day instead of the
character we should be rooting for
because of just how overpowered he is
burning the rest into ashes I'll pick
for the next entry is from the recent
bleach
school's epithet the overkill allows him
to become stronger with each opponent he
kills having already killed 100
Shinigami and another hundred previously
he prepares to deliver the Fatal blow to
another Lieutenant but Yamamoto
intercepts the attack recognizing
Yamamoto Driscoll lost maniacally before
declaring he shall kill Yamamoto with
his own subordinates Bankai despite
Driscoll striking him multiple times
with devastating bolts of lightning
Yamamoto emerges and injured and
brutally kills Driscoll with a single
Slash from his shikai ryujin jaka
burning the very flesh from his bones
engulfed in flames Driscoll's bones are
ultimately reduced to Cinders one slash
was all it took to burn Quincy without
leaving him to even make a sound and all
that Yamamoto ever said was burn just
goes to show that you don't want to piss
off the old man in an organization full
of young people
and finally we have Luffy's one punch
knockout against Bellamy in one piece
the fight was short but the reason for
this entry taking the top spot is
because of the build up to that
satisfying one punch KO Bellamy was set
up to be this infuriating villain when
he beat both Luffy and Zoro when they
first met after Luffy learned that
Bellamy had attacked Cricket's house and
stolen the gold artifacts as most
pirates do Luffy fights Bellamy to steal
the gold back like another pirate does
Bellamy mostly showed off his best Pixar
logo impression but Luffy didn't even
lift a finger because he's a throwaway
simp through and through for his final
attack Bellamy rocketed towards Luffy
preparing to Goomba stomp him but with
the single most satisfying punch in one
piece history Luffy smashed Bellamy to
the ground leaving an imprint of his
knuckles on the right side of his face
and knocking him out cold the spring
sound effect of Bellamy's legs was
amazing and it's mostly the emotional
weight that carries the scene this is a
well-deserved punch that we all wanted
to see there's even a moment when one of
the gang members brings a wanted poster
of Luffy that shows his new Bounty of a
hundred million and Bellamy just thinks
it's fake because he thought Luffy was
weak but in their next encounter Luffy
leaves a fist-sized mark on his face all
worth it for that one punch payoff the
satisfaction we all felt as Bellamy got
his lights rightfully knocked out is
what elevates this scene from epic to
memorable in my opinion and proves the
rule in one piece that one must never
fight a serious Luffy and that ends part
two of our one hit chaos list let me
know what other one-hit chaos you'd like
to see being recognized in the comments
section down below like share and
subscribe I'm glad to have you here and
thank you so much again for watching
this video